je voulais voir un peu pour un petit
cadeau pour pack wii en doudou plutôt la
boutique de béatrice roux est un univers
à part moelleux et coloré peuplé de
doudou rassurant dragons contre les
cauchemars moutons coussins et coeur à
parfumer entre 5 et 50 euros les modèles
à adopter se décline à l'infini
à oreille marche bien je n'aurais pas
cru que ça prenne de l'ampleur comme ça
surtout nous à la campagne quand même et
en fait
ouais ça ça a du succès le défi que
béatrice s'élancer en 2018 est donc
relevé à l'époque cette cadre supérieure
coût des peluches pour ses proches après
plusieurs mois de réflexion elle se
lance avec sa machine à coudre et
quelques économies je me suis dit mais
entre les doudous et puis le zéro déchet
finalement il ya peut-être quelque chose
à creuser donc j'ai monté un projet et
puis j'ai budgété tout et j'ai fait un
prévisionnel comme tout le monde et puis
je me suis dit que c'était jouable donc
à condition de faire ça ça ça ça et ça
donc je me suis fait une feuille de
route sur trois ans alors pour intimider
ses adversaires et d'ours et lé fait du
bruit de serpents ah oui ça c'est des
ailes alors ça ça va pas être évident
moi j'aime bien dire que je suis
facilitatrice de rêve plutôt que
couturière puisque l'idée c'est vraiment
de proposer aux gens de leur fabriquer
l'objet dont ils ont envie depuis le
confinement le rêve et le consommer
local sont à la mode
67% des jeunes mamans sont plus
attentives au lieu de fabrication des
produits de puériculture et 51%
s'attache aux valeurs de la marque une
chance car ouvrir son commerce demande
un investissement important la
difficulté c'était de passer de mon
petit stand de marché où j'ai trois
mètres sur trois à une boutique qui fait
28 mètres carrés et qui doit jamais être
vide en fait tout ça avec les commandes
spéciales
et puis je fais de la retouche aussi
donc aussi que je puisse répondre aux
retouches aux réparations etc dans un
temps quand même acceptable pour le
client ça suppose une trésorerie
importante et moi je voulais pas
emprunter je voulais vraiment le faire
progressivement
bonjour à sombernon l'artisanat
bénéficier de la solidarité de colette
en 2020 cette commerçante voisine lui a
prêté un local pour tester son modèle
économique elles vont toujours ces
produits là dans le coup leur accord là
des petits doigts de fée elle va nous
créer des petites choses qu'on verra pas
partout franchement j'adore son travail
donc
voilà pourquoi pas
le présenter dans notre boutique pour
qu'elle puisse se développer un petit
peu après
béatrice roux n'est pas la seule à
fabriquer des doudous en bourgogne créée
en 2016 l'entreprise creusotine d'un vin
connaît un succès fulgurant elle compte
désormais six salariés et vente 40 mille
pièces par an les fabricants de peluches
sont portées par le dynamisme du marché
du jouet 3% de croissance pour un total
de 3,7 milliards d'euros en 2021 le made
in france représente 14% des ventes
de quoi inciter amalia perrier a quitté
son emploi de stylistes dans le
prêt-à-porter de luxe
la dijonnaise de 26 ans lance marguerite
et georges en 2019 je suis parti sur le
concept d'une poupée qu'on habille et
qu'on déshabille et de là j'ai voulu
créer un modèle pour les plus petits ça
sert la toute première souris qui
ressemble plus cher à une poule et cinq
prototypes plus tard il ya eu le modèle
définitif de la popeline qui aimait le
succès arrive rapidement en 2021 amalia
et reconnue artisans d'art elle vend
environ 2000 popeline parents toute
différente sans compter les centaines de
doudou et les grandes poupées sur mesure
on va être réglé les mains sur les bras
un endroit comprendre au début je
voulais vraiment travailler seul et
maintenant j'ai bien vu que en fait je
ne peux pas produire autant qu'on me le
demande donc j'ai été obligé de de me
créer une à qui les poupées dijonnais
sont vendus entre 50 et 200 euros en
fonction des modèles pour ça vraiment
porteur d'espoir à la fois pour ce que
ça veut dire au niveau de la façon de
consommer des gens d'avoir des produits
comme ça créés par des artisans rente
plutôt que les grandes industries
une fois terminé chaque popeline prend
la pause car 30% des ventes se font par
internet six boutiques les distribue
aussi de taiwan à new york ou juste au
bout de la rue à dijon
c'est un rêve c'est je suis indépendante
je gagne ma vie tout seul et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose que je n'aurais
pas pensé faire avant et est quelque
chose que je pense est inatteignable en
conjuguant production locale et
ouverture sur le monde les artisanes
modem réalisent leurs projets un doute
voit la main